Okay,
let's go back to the pigeon hole thing
here.
How do you clean your room when your
spouse doesn't share that goal?
Huh?
Well,
that's another one of those questions.
It's really hard to answer because I
don't have the details,
you know,
how do you clean your room?
What goals does your spouse have?
That's the first take.
I mean,
is there some commonality?
it might be maybe your spouse as much
more disorderly than you or less
conscientious or irritated at you for
all sorts of reasons.
You know,
the first thing you could do is,
um,
try to lead by example and see how that
works.
But you may have to argue and fight it
out,
you know,
um,
break it down into sub tasks and,
and see if you can distribute the tasks
and,
and negotiate you have to negotiate.
And without further information,
I can't say much more than that.
You know,
you can say why you're doing it,
what you think the goal we're and goal
was and that you'd like some help and
maybe there's something you could offer
in return.
Um,
if you can't negotiate at all with your
spouse,
then you have a much broader problem
than how do you clean your room when
you're supposed doesn't share that goal
because the real problem would be how do
you learn to negotiate with your spouse?
I could talk about that a little bit.
I mean,
the first thing that you have to do,
if you want to negotiate with someone is
be able to say no.
The second thing is to have something to
offer.
The third thing is to find out what they
want and to know what you want.
You know,
because often people,
especially with people that love them,
they say,
well,
if you really knew,
if you really love me,
then you'd know what I want.
It's like,
no,
that's just wrong.
The person that you are in love with or
living with isn't any smarter than you.
And so you pretty much always have to
tell people straight out what you want
and then you have to let them be really
stupid about giving it to you for quite
a while.
You know?
So sometimes I've recommended to my
clients that they take their wife or
husband out on a date and of course
they're all skeptical about that and
cynical about it and then they go on a
date and they have a terrible time and
they come back and say,
oh,
I told you that was a stupid idea,
and I tell them that,
hey,
you're not gonna do anything romantic
with your spouse for the next 40 years.
That's your plan.
That's the plan is that it's like you
might have to go out to a movie after
you haven't been good to each other for
like five years.
You might have to go out to movie 10
times movie and dinner,
say before it starts to become fun
again.
It's like it's hard to do that sort of
thing,
right?
You don't.
People think those things are easy and
they're not.
So anyways,
you have to,
you have to learn to negotiate with your
spouse.
And that's a very difficult thing to do.
So I'm figuring out what you want is a
good way to start.
So.